what's it like trying to read as a
dyslexic you see things backwards you
just don't know you see them that way
here's a good example some of the First
videos I made I would just go out and
drive around town and do errands like
what's it like to go get groceries with
a exotic car and I'd Park in a meter and
you'd have to pay for it right and I'd
be like just paying for the Lamborghinis
parking I'm at meter blah blah blah blah
blah and go on about my day then I get
home later and I'd be editing the
footage and I would realize I read the
damn meter numbers backwards and I would
do this every time that's 36 years old
when it finally hit me what it was to be
dyslexic